on retrouve Véronique à Québec et à
Québec également Jonathan Trudeau
bonsoir à vous deux
on a plein les bras il y a quand même
des questions qui peuvent commencer à se
poser qu'on le voit depuis quelques
jours Véronique et Jonathan sur
mais on va devoir s'adapter on va devoir
investir on va devoir faire ceci cela je
vous fais entendre les oppositions à
Québec la réponse de monsieur Legault
puis on revient
moi je pense que nous devons mettre à
jour tous nos plans d'action puis en
amont on le réitère là ça fait cinq ans
qu'on le demande d'avoir un plan du
gouvernement qui soit complet ce qu'on a
pas par rapport à la lutte au changement
climatique
moi je souhaite que le printemps 2023
soit un point tournant et qu'à partir de
maintenant l'adaptation au changement
climatique ça soit une véritable
priorité nationale
on peut plus traiter ça comme un dossier
comme les autres il y a un aspect de
planification de l'adaptation au
changement climatique qui doit
absolument être débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a une question de
ressources il y a une question de
cohérence de nos politiques publiques
sur la place du pétrole dans notre
économie sur l'émission de gaz à effet
de serre toutes ces questions là ont été
difficiles à aborder avec le
gouvernement
on a annoncé déjà un milliard et demi en
adaptation au changement climatique on a
eu des demandes des municipalités qui
incluaient pas la couverture des feux de
forêt donc les besoins évoluent puis on
va continuer d'investir en adaptation au
changement climatique
en fait monsieur Legault viennent le
reconnaître d'une certaine façon il dit
ça comprenait même pas les feux de forêt
ce qu'on nous avait présenté Véronique
et Jonathan comme comme grand plan de
puis on en a beaucoup parlé à l'époque
de départ qui était demandé mais c'est
un sujet que qu'on doit aborder
Véronique là c'est clair oui en fait
l'argument du gouvernement le goût par
rapport aux municipalités aux villes qui
demandait 2 milliards pour s'adapter au
changement climatique a toujours été le
même c'est-à-dire on peut pas vous
donner de l'argent puis après ça
l'argent dépensé d'une manière
différente d'une ville à l'autre en fait
ce que le gouvernement est prêt à faire
si je comprends bien c'est d'y aller à
la pièce c'est à dire présentez-nous des
projets dites nous ce que vous voulez
faire puis quand ça va être concret au
lieu de vous donner une enveloppe
financer le projet en question si on
trouve effectivement que ça répond aux
besoins de changement climatique puis
d'adaptation et tout ça donc c'est pour
ça que Monsieur le goût
comme une pointe comme quoi voyez-vous
l'argent si on l'avait donné sans poser
de questions mais il y en aurait pas qui
aurait été
investioportrait
par contre ce que les parties de
position disent un consensus là-dessus
là il faut au Québec qu'on trouve une
manière de cesser d'être en réaction et
de faire plus de prévention puis un post
mortemment qui va être fait cette année
après les inondations après les feux de
forêt là ça s'enchaîne un événement
après l'autre c'est clair que le
gouvernement doit se pencher sur comment
on procède à l'avenir comment on se
prépare parce que il va y en avoir
d'autres et ce n'est pas qu'au Québec
Jonathan partout on le voit il y a pas
assez d'avion au Canada d'avions assisté
en c'est comme si on se réveillait puis
là on s'aperçoit que ça peut peut-être
survenir plus souvent ce genre de choses
c'est qu'il y a deux éléments il y a la
crise actuelle qu'on doit gérer
là-dessus sans y avoir un beau consensus
une belle solidarité et le fait que ces
événements-là viennent mettre en lumière
toute la question le débat sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique
vous l'avez dispatrices il y a pas juste
au Québec on a des problématiques face
au changement climatiques par contre
celle des feux de forêt elle était un
peu dans l'anglement autant du
gouvernement que des municipalités moi
j'ai épluché le fameux document de lui
MQ qui parle de 2 millions par année
nécessaire pour l'adaptation au
changement climatique et à peine une ou
deux lignes sur le fait qu'il était pas
en mesure de chiffrer les impacts des
autres événements extrêmes tels les
épisodes de chaleur et les feux de forêt
donc on peut pas dire par exemple que le
gouvernement n'a pas ne pas agir donc il
y a une discussion qui est nécessaire je
pense qu'on doit la faire on doit garder
la tête froide là on ne peut pas sauter
aux conclusions immédiatement mais là où
j'invite différents intervenants au
niveau autant politique que des groupes
de pression où je les invite à la
prudence c'est espèce de réflexe de
pointé du doigt par exemple le
gouvernement le goût pour des événements
qui ont cours en ce moment soyons bien
clair je parlais avec quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît très très bien matière de climat
dans un monde dans un univers parallèle
ou le Québec aurait atteint depuis
quelques années par exemple le zéro
émission de GES on aurait quand même les
incendies de forêts qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire de lien
entre les émissions du Québec qui a une
petite part à jouer qui oui doit
s'améliorer mais qui a une petite part à
jouer et un contexte qui est carrément
mondial qui est planétaire ouais bien
sûr mais moi maudit c'est pas une
question moyen
financier c'est pas le thé aujourd'hui
ils vont l'avoir ils vont la sauf que
nous demande l'argent ils vont l'avoir
n'importe quelle ressource en ce moment
on va leur donner sauf que on
ce qu'ils veulent c'est de savoir
exactement voilà genre c'est ça que je
comprends on a vu par ailleurs sur le
sur dans l'immédiat la gestion de
monsieur Legault ça nous rappelle un peu
la gestion de la covid il est très
présent il est l'enlever en première
ligne il est allé on le voit avec des
cartes avec les gens de la subscru etc
donc monsieur Legault on le sent
davantage à l'aise avec ce genre de
gestion de crise Jonathan
absolument il est davantage à l'aise que
dans l'arène politique dans la joute
partisane ceci étant dit ce serait ce
serait de mauvaise foi par exemple que
d'affirmer que ce qui se passe en ce
moment en ce moment fait l'affaire de
François Legault qui l’en fait plus pour
oublier le fait que c'est plus difficile
à l'Assemblée nationale mais
effectivement les Québécois qui retrouve
le François Legault qui est rassembleur
qui a les les bons mots même je voyais
juste au niveau de l'image là il y a eu
un ajustement aujourd'hui François
Legault qui lui aussi avait le petit
manteau de la sécurité publique semble
bien en contrôle évidemment tout ne peut
pas être parfait il y a des informations
qui l'information qui évolue rapidement
qui peuvent être divergentes on a vu
Clover un peu plus tôt cette semaine le
bon il y a la situation avec
l'évacuation qui était envisagée avec
mysticini ou le Premier ministre c'est
peut-être un peu trop avancé mais somme
toute il reste que François Lego je
pense dans des
circonstances comme celle-là revêt très
bien ses habits de Premier ministre et
Véronique puis à des panels politiques
ont souligne ce qui va pas bien normal
puis je vous souligne que m'annoncer la
mairesse de chez bougamo tout à l'heure
nous a dit
la SQ les la sécurité publique là tout
le monde toutes les agences
gouvernementales ont travaillé dans son
école depuis hier plusieurs autres jours
mais pour l'évacuation de manière
exemplaire donc des plans d'urgence dans
les municipalités ça peut fonctionner
aussi on le voit là oui puis d'ailleurs
chapeau au maire aux mairesse qui sont
sur place aux élus municipaux on a
tendance parfois à minimiser leur rôle
mais c'est là qu'on voit qu'en temps de
crise ils ont un rôle même quasiment
plus important que que pour la
population locale que le gouvernement
national participant sur le terrain puis
je trouve que dans les derniers jours
chacun a bien communiquer c'est à dire
que tout le monde a été solidaire il y a
des il y a des appels qui ont été lancés
personne à céder à la panique c'est à
dire que on garde un peu tout le monde
en disant soyez prudent écoutez les
consignes mais personne ne cède à la
panique puis il y a beaucoup d'entre
elles aussi des citoyens sur les pages
facebook qui disent ben moi j'ai de la
pêche chez moi je lis dans mon sol venez
alors c'est là où on retrouve justement
cet esprit qu'on a vu au début de la
pandémie lorsqu'on était face à
l'inconnu
du ministère de la Sécurité publique des
fois au niveau administratif après des
événements inondations et tout ça il
peut y avoir des lenteurs des lacunes
sauf que en termes opérationnel ce
ministère là à mon sens et le plus
performant du gouvernement du Québec moi
dans le passé lorsque j'étais en
politique j'ai travaillé de près avec
eux dans dans deux tragies il y avait
des inondations à rivière au renard en
Gaspésie qui avait fait deux décès je me
souviens aussi du séisme en Haïti en
2010 ou moi j'étais au cabinet du
premier ministre on travaillait en
proximité évidemment que la sécurité
publique pour l'accueil des
ressortissants n'aura pas des dépôts et
tout ça et là-dessus on peut être
critique envers bien des ministères mais
le ministère la sécurité publique au
Québec il est exemplaire bon ben voilà
ce qu'ils disent qu'on n'est jamais
positif voici on va vous envoyer
l'enregistrement un mot
Maxime Bernier j'hésitais hier en Paris
tellement farfelu mais mais c'est la
reine politique Steven je vous montre
d'ailleurs d'abord ce qu'il a écrit et
sur Twitter et sur Facebook il dit je
gage qu'une bonne partie des feux de
forêt est allumée par des terroristes
verts pour donner un coup de pouce alors
campagne de changement climatique
l'extrême gauche est experte pour
inventer créer des crises qu'elle peut
ensuite exploiter réaction de du
ministre Guilbaud qu'on écoute
on envoie des gens comme ça du côté du
Parti conservateur du Canada qui se lève
en chambre de temps en temps pour nier
l'existence même des changements
climatiques c'est quand même incroyable
que ce bonhomme là a été ministre des
Affaires étrangères sur un gouvernement
conservateur je pense que c'est en dit
long sur le gouvernement conservateur et
la priorité qu'il donne à des dossiers
comme celui des changements climatiques
alors que dire Jonathan ce dernier
ce serait drôle c'était possible
dangereux comme propos moi je dois vous
dire Patrice que je n'ai pas pu le voir
ce tweet-là parce que je suis bloqué du
compte de Maxime Berny je pense que
c'est après la foi où j'avais dit qu'il
était plus un politicien qui était
devenu un clown agitateur
il démontre encore que c'était
essentiellement ce qu'il est devenu mais
ce qui est ce qui est dommage c'est de
voir qu'il y a un tirant d'eau là il y a
des gens qui véhiculent ça qui prennent
ça au sérieux et ça vient ça vient
mettre
la friture sur la ligne qui est
absolument pas nécessaire dans un moment
où on doit tous être mobilisé si on veut
parce que des limites Véronique a joué
avec les fêtes de n'importe quoi c'est
un peu solide quand on était lui il y a
une responsabilité qui vient avec je
viens de vous dire il y a un instant que
le rôle des élus dans une gestion de
crise c'est de ne posséder à la panique
et au contraire de lancer des appels au
calme des messages comme ça peuvent
semer la confusion ça peut envoyer des
messages contradictoires et
ultimement des messages contradictoires
ça peut nuire à la sécurité des gens
parce qu'il y en a qui pourraient dire
moi je vais rester chez nous moi je vais
pas évacuer ma maison parce que je pense
que c'est faux ce que les autorités me
disent alors ça c'est dangereux
justement les gens qui peuvent résister
de cette façon-là alors en quelque part
les élus ont cette responsabilités
parfois même s'ils sont pas d'accord
politiquement avec tout là et ont quand
même une responsabilité d'être solidaire
pour gérer la crise non mais il peut
même aller aussi loin que douter de
certains nombres de choses sur les
changements climatiques mais mettez dire
que des gens de Google allume des feux
pour créer une crise toute pièce il
était quand même je vous le rappelle au
débat des chefs la dernière fois là
c'est pour ça que entre autres on en
parle Jonathan Trudeau Véronique prince
merci beaucoup à très bientôt bonne
soirée à vous bonne soirée bonne soirée